madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois mais cher collègue
sans ordre républicain il n'y a ni
sécurité ni liberté
cet ordre ce sont les policiers et les
gendarmes sur notre sol qui la sûr ils
sont exposés à des risques quotidiens en
notre nom c'est pourquoi il mérite le
soutien de la puissance publique et la
reconnaissance de la Nation
ainsi s'exprimer le président de la
République dans son adresse aux Français
du 14 juin 2020
dedans plus tard c'est ce soutien de la
puissance publique à nos forces de
sécurité intérieure que nous traduisons
ici en carnet de route pour les 5 années
à venir un soutien que notre majorité
présidentielle n'a cessé de démontrer
depuis 2017 à travers plusieurs lois
d'importance et aujourd'hui nous nous
engageons à poursuivre dans ce sens
grâce à une traduction budgétaire à
l'ensemble de ces mesures avec cette loi
de programmation et d'orientation du
ministère de l'Intérieur pour la
première fois il s'agit de donner une
vision globale de l'action du ministère
de l'Intérieur et de ses agents qui font
un travail remarquable au quotidien au
service de nos concitoyens et nous
souhaitons tous ici j'en suis certaine
les en remercier vivement
le texte que nous nous apprêtons à
adopter portant lui une véritable
ambition afin de permettre à nos
policiers et nos gendarmes qu'ils soient
sur le terrain ou dans les bureaux ainsi
qu'à tous les acteurs du continent de
sécurité de remplir au mieux leurs
missions au service de chacun de nos
concitoyens au cœur de nos territoires
il ne s'agit pas ici de définir des
objectifs sécurité mais bien de donner
les moyens humains technologiques et
financier à nos forces de l'ordre pour
assurer leur mission
leur mission qui est de nous protéger de
protéger nos biens nos bâtiments de
protéger nos enfants de protéger notre
République
nous protéger pour permettre à tous de
vivre avec l'assurance que l'ensemble
des services du ministère oeuvre
pleinement à la sécurité de chacune et
de chacun les femmes et les hommes tous
les acteurs de cette chaîne de sécurité
méritent la reconnaissance de la nation
et de la représentation nationale
c'est pourquoi je regrette profondément
que certains dérapages et propos
déplacés la semaine passée parfois même
un outrancier et été entendu dans cette
hémicycle malgré cela nous avons pu
effectuer un véritable travail de
co-construction avec les uns et les
autres pour déboucher sur un texte qui
nous semble équilibré pragmatique et
ambitieux pour être aux avant-postes de
la sécurité de notre pays
issus de toutes les sensibilités nous
avons adopté de nombreux amendements qui
permettent de belles avancées plusieurs
amendements du groupe démocrate ont été
adoptés et nous nous en réjouissons je
pense notamment à se porter par notre
collègue Philippe la tombe en matière de
lutte contre la cybercriminel
criminalité
Erwan Malan sur la lutte contre les
violences sexistes et sexuelles ou les
précisions apportées par Laurence
bischner ski dans le rapport annexé sur
la réforme de la police judiciaire
ces garanties que nous avons inscrites
dans la loop me lors de l'examen
commission ou encore été renforcés en
séance avec l'adoption d'un amendement
du gouvernement et de notre collègue
comme vous tous ici nous serons
vigilants sur la conduite de cette
réforme et le respect des équilibre
nécessaire à la préservation de
l'indépendance de la police judiciaire
nous avons entendu vos engagements vos
assurances monsieur le ministre et nous
vous en remercions
je souhaite d'ailleurs saluer l'écoute
et l'ouverture dont vous avez fait
preuve tout au long de nos débats et qui
nous ont permis d'avancer ensemble dans
la bonne direction
j'en profite également pour vous
remercier monsieur le rapporteur pour la
qualité de votre travail
chers collègues tous ces jours passés
ensemble en commission et en séance pour
débattre de ce projet de loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur ont été riches
d'échanges de réponse précise et de
mesure qui nous n'en doutons pas
permettront à l'institution d'être à la
hauteur des attentes de nos concitoyens
et des crises auxquelles nous pourrions
être confrontés dans l'avenir le groupe
démocrate votera avec conviction en
faveur de ce texte je vous remercie